[Music]
joshua is in west virginia
hi joshua welcome to the dave ramsey
show
happy to be here thank you uh mr ramsay
thank you i have a question
okay uh the question i have is
um i live in a double-wide it's a mobile
home
and um the problem is it's on my parents
property
and i've tried to talk to them numerous
times about
uh purchasing the property from them and
putting it more permanently in my name
currently right now i have a piece of
paper that i had to sign with the uh
the mortgage company that's financing
the double wide
and it's basically if i ever had a
falling out or anything like that that i
would still be able to uh
i guess keep the uh the house here on
the property
but um i've had some issues with my
parents you know they don't want to sell
me the property or anything else
and it's gonna cost me about twenty
thousand dollars to move it up or to
move it from
uh where it's at to a different place
and
probably i'm looking at about ten to
twenty thousand dollars additionally
just to find property
and uh what do you owe on
44 000 okay
um well
what you're telling me is is that this
doesn't work long term
right that there's nothing on fire per
se
but it's not a good long term plan a
it's a double wide going down in value b
you don't own the property under nor are
you likely to
so that leads us to the conclusion we've
got to get rid of it how are we going to
get rid of it
well uh my wife and i we've
thought about talking to a realtor about
it
and the real estate agent said that
oftentimes
they can sell them but they said it's
it's very hard to sell it without
it being on a permanent piece of land
that's very true
that's my dilemma yeah that's very true
but but what is your what's your
household income
uh right now it's i went from 35 000
a year got a pay raise this year and uh
we should be making about
55 to 60k this year if everything
stays the way it's going joshua is this
on a permanent foundation
it's under stucco yes that's what they
consider as permanent foundation
yeah but it's not his lands it doesn't
matter mom and dad make
or do they have any money no
actually uh for the past few months
probably shouldn't say this but i'll
just be truthful with you
my parents are both on disability and
we've been trying to help them stay
afloat on their bills and it's been
dragging us down financially as well
[Music]
okay um well
what i what i think is you're probably
going to sell this mobile home for 20 or
30
000 bucks to a mobile home lot who comes
and picks it up
and you're going to have to borrow the
difference
this is like a car that you're upside
down in
is basically what it is and uh then
you're gonna go rent
for a little while somewhere until you
get that
note paid off and then you'll save up
your uh
down payment are you a member of a good
credit union for instance
currently right now i i use a credit
union as a bank
and the credit union the lender that i'm
through with right now
is also credit union as well okay then
they may work with you to let you sign a
note for whatever it doesn't
bring but you need to start talking to
them
about this house this has to be sold
we have to move and there's nothing on
fire
but you don't need to be sitting here
two years from now
still twirling around in all this
dysfunctional mess
we've had this going on since about 2015
2015 i was
i was working in the coal industry i was
bringing 95 000
a year coal industry drops out more or
less i get the
the the rug jerked out from underneath
my feet and yeah
that's when a lot of things started
going downhill from there yeah well it
went downhill when you bought this just
when it went downhill
because it's been going downhill ever
since you bought it so
um we got it we got to stop the bleeding
and get rid of the thing
so let's have a goal of being out of the
mobile home business into a rental by
next spring
and sign a note for the difference with
one of the credit unions
so let's say you can get it sold for 30
or whatever then you sign a note for 14
or if you solve for 20 you're going to
sign
up for 24. it's just going to take you a
while to dig out of this
but it's not going to get any better
waiting right because it's not going
up in value and joshua you are going to
have to be
proactive as you talk to this credit
union and to this lender
uh that you know this isn't something
that's optional this is not something
you're thinking this is a five-year
struggle
and this is the direction you're going
and explain to them your situation
uh and you're gonna have to follow up on
it don't wait on them to make a decision
you follow up with them and call and
call and call
yeah i gotta finance the difference or
i'm handing you guys the keys and you
can come get it
right well you know this is the if if
they won't work with you we're going to
have to have
some other conversations here deed in
lieu of foreclosure yeah this is not
going to go well
but it's going to mess up your life if
you go that route i would much rather
you just sign a note for the difference
and get rid of it
and um then lesson learned mobile homes
go down in value they are not
something you buy and uh lesson learned
i don't put
mobile homes or houses on other people's
land
that's exactly right even if it's my
parents and that little piece of paper
means
nothing yeah yeah well it doesn't it's
it's just
it allows him to sit there and allow
them to get the mortgage on the mobile
home is all it was
so um but yeah it's it's problematic and
it sounds like your parents are in a
mess too so
i'm sorry sorry you guys are facing all
that